the beloved actress who gave away the
entire plot of her movie on national
television the actor from a massive film
franchise spoiling their character's
death and which actor got fired for his
mistake keep watching to be shocked
about these spoilers
david prouse played darth vader in the
original star wars trilogy or at least
he was the guy in the vader costume and
helmet james earl jones provided the
voice and sebastian shaw played the
unmasked villain at the end of return of
the jedi prowse's image wasn't as well
known as those of co-stars like mark
hamill or harrison ford but the first
wave of star wars mania in 1978 was so
huge that a proust meet and greet in
berkeley california drew 1 000 people
the british actor delighted the audience
at the event with stories about his
career and the first star wars movie
including news that a sequel was in
pre-production krause promised that star
wars 2 would feature a lightsaber battle
between luke skywalker and darth vader
and then he said that darth vader would
reveal to luke that he was his father
star wars 2 became the empire strikes
back of course and it featured the exact
same twist prous had spoiled years
before that's impossible
prowse wasn't the only cast member from
the empire strikes back to spoil the
movie billy dee williams who played the
irresistibly roguish lando calrissian
spilled another star wars secret but on
a much higher profile venue nbc's
long-running morning show today to be
fair williams had to reveal that lando
wasn't really a bad guy just a crafty
manipulator he seemed to get a little
defensive when the interviewer labeled
his character as evil and decided to
interject he's not evil he's just a guy
caught in a situation in the grand
scheme of star wars spoilers it's a
pretty minor reveal but on the other
hand it did ruin a pretty significant
plot twist for anyone who watched the
interview before the movie
like most time travel movies the time
traveler's wife has a complicated
premise that makes for a fine line then
between explaining a movie's plot and
spoiling the movie entirely the time
traveler's wife star rachel mcadams
accidentally crossed that line while
promoting the film on the daily show
host jon stewart asked how far outside
the present the story's time-traveling
husband was able to journey and mcadams
explained he goes as far as his own
childhood he goes forward as far as his
own death after a moment of silence in
which mcadams realized what she'd done
stewart replied whoa he knows how he's
gonna die before he dies mcadams a
little embarrassed sighed now we've
ruined everything
it's probably worth mentioning that the
movie was based on the 2003 bestseller
of the same name and fans of the book
most definitely were already aware of
the title character's fate still
promoting a film romance by spoiling a
death is usually not the best way to go
sylvester stallone produced and earned a
best supporting actor nomination for his
role in creed a rocky franchise spin-off
that helped revive the blockbuster
series he created in the 70s in 2014 he
tweeted out an artsy sentimental photo
of the filmmaking process behind the
film with the caption where the
screenwriting is done the picture showed
a pair of glasses some handwritten notes
and the last page of the script for
creed the page was upside down but if
his fans wanted to know how the movie
ended all they had to do was flip the
photo and zoom in a little
game of thrones fans were thrilled when
it was announced that ian mcshane from
deadwood would join the cast of hbo's
epic fantasy series in its sixth season
in an interview on bbc breakfast about
his role as brother ray however he gave
a little too much away mcshane said i
bring back a much-loved character
everyone you think is dead vanity fair
connected the dots and determined that
mcshane meant the hound as actor rory
mccann had been spotted on set informed
he'd upset some people with his casual
plot spoiling mcshane offered game of
thrones fans a verbal eye roll he told
the telegraph
you say the slightest thing and the
internet goes ape i was accused of
giving the plot away but i just think
get a life
logan marked the end of hugh jackman's
17-year journey playing wolverine across
eight x-men films and while the x-men
franchise will continue with the heroes
played by younger actors wolverine
doesn't really age so there was
essentially only one way that the
character and jackman's portrayal of him
could end with wolverine's death still
it wasn't cool when jackman on the week
logan hit theaters told entertainment
weekly that's how it ended he revealed
in the end he must give his life to save
someone else i thought that was really
powerful he wasn't wrong although it
might have been even more powerful if
he'd managed to keep it to himself
millions of people were excited for
rogue one the first in a planned series
of stand-alone star wars spin-off movies
among the most pumped the people who
took time out of their lives to attend
star wars celebration europe where actor
jang wen blew the rogue one ending for
everyone watching the conference gwen
portrayed baez malbas one of the members
of the ragtag group who comes together
to steal the plans for the death star to
stop the empire baze heroically dies in
his mission which when mentioned during
a live stream star wars celebration
panel he would have revealed more
details had panel host gwendolyn
christie not cut him off warning i think
you've gotta leave it there
by the time avengers infinity war hit
theaters in 2018 mark ruffalo had played
the famously green-skinned muscle man
the hulk in five marvel cinematic
universe movies but somehow he wound up
leaking significant details of two of
those highly anticipated films before
they were released for the public
infinity war is the first in a two film
avengers finale and features a brutal
and sad twist ending in which
intergalactic villain thanos snaps half
of all life out of existence including
many of the avengers it's unbelievable
and it's even more unbelievable that
ruffalo told the world such events would
happen during an appearance on good
morning america nearly a year before
infinity war would arrive at cineplexes
ruffalo teased wait till you see this
next one everybody died
not everybody
no
not long after the good morning america
incident ruffalo attended the premiere
of the 2017 mcu entry thor ragnarok in
which he co-stars as the hulk at the
premiere he accidentally shared the
movie with anyone watching his instagram
live feed by forgetting to switch off
insta before putting his phone in his
pocket ruffalo accidentally streamed the
first 20 minutes of the movie's audio
over the internet
tom holland is a versatile actor and
international celebrity who does two
things more than anything else in his
busy career he plays spider-man whenever
the mcu requires him to do so and he
routinely spoils sensitive or top-secret
details about those same mcu films in
june 2018 holland put in an appearance
at ace seattle comic-con and posted a
video to his instagram page to calm down
fans eager for details about his
upcoming second spider-man film tom said
these words before ironically and
accidentally revealing the movie's name
i wanted to apologize because there's no
real revelations coming out this weekend
about spider-man 2. i got the new script
i'm super excited to read it it's gonna
be great the funniest part is that
holland said all this while holding up
the ipad upon which he was reading the
script with the not yet public title
spider-man far from home very visible
here's a spoiler alert for avengers
infinity war spider-man dies in the end
a crowd filled a theater at the arc
light in los angeles for a special early
screening of that film hosted by
directors joe and anthony russo along
with some of the cast members holland
came out on stage and quipped i'm alive
though obviously confused about whether
he was walking out before or after the
screening holland coyly but clearly
revealed his character's fate that was a
test right
there's uh nobody back there yes you
passed
plenty of superhero movies are also
origin stories that lay the groundwork
for future sequels by showing how a
regular individual acquires their
superpowers and embraces their
extraordinary lot in life aquaman the
2018 mega blockbuster entry and dc
comics cinematic universe features jason
momoa as the title lord of the seas
reprising the role he plays in 2017's
team-up movie justice league at the time
film-goers might not all have
anticipated aquaman to be an origin
story that takes place before the events
of justice league but they soon found
out as much thanks to an excitable mamoa
sharing a little too much about the
movie particularly its ending and his
character's arc during his promotional
rounds for justice league as he told sfx
magazine he's not even really aquaman
yet he's not the king of the seven seas
we don't really get there until my solo
movie at the end really it's a huge
growth for me it's a gigantic arc for
arthur curry
guardians of the galaxy was something of
a surprise hit in 2014 because it's
based on more obscure source material
than previously successful mcu outings
like iron man captain america and thor
only relatively hardcore comics fans
knew what to expect from guardians
hardly anybody could predict how events
would unfold in guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 which hit theaters in 2017. the
sequel adds mysterious new characters to
the mix including aisha played by
australian actor elizabeth debigi while
discussing and promoting the movie at
san diego comic-con in the summer of
2016 which was a year before the film
would see release debi laid out most of
aisha's arc unfortunately she also
included one of the film's twists she
isn't one of the good guys in fact aisha
is a villain who tricks the protagonists
into fighting on her behalf as she told
gizmodo at san diego comic-con aisha is
this leader of the sovereign people she
enlists the guardians to help her fight
a sort of galactic beast it's all going
swimmingly until it all turns very very
sour let's just say it goes from amiable
to not so amiable quite quickly actor
rodri martin works primarily in spanish
language media in 2021 he landed a very
plum gig performing the dub for actor
evan peters in the spanish version of
the disney plus mcu series juan division
peter's appearance on the show as pietro
maximoff who was presumed dead is a mega
surprise in the complicated slow boil
world of wand division according to sin
exception martin revealed his casting on
twitter ahead of pietro's big episode 5
reveal which violated martin's
confidentiality agreement with disney
and marvel martin also told twitter that
he'd been dubbing peter's lines in
future mcu projects which means
ironically at that point martin either
didn't really know how one division ends
or was trying to throw fans off the
track of figuring out the real deal with
pietro the source states that for
potentially spoiling multiple projects
and ignoring contract language disney
terminated martin and replaced him with
manuel gemeno the actor who performed
the dubs for charlie cox in marvel's
daredevil series
while the star wars prequels weren't as
well received as the original trilogy
there are some undeniably great elements
of the films such as the always terrific
samuel l jackson as a jedi named mace
windu prior to the release of the final
prequel revenge of the sith jackson sat
for an interview with now playing when
asked what windu would be doing in the
film jackson answered dying he then
added that he couldn't go into too much
detail but that his character would face
an awesome death of course hardcore star
wars fans were already aware that the
jedi faced near total extinction during
the events leading up to the original
trilogy so windu's death wasn't totally
a surprise still having it confirmed
this way counts as something of a
disturbance in the force
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite talkative actors are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]